major breaking news on the rollout of
the coveted booster shot affecting
millions of americans cdc director
rachelle wolinski has overruled a cdc
panel to expand the number of people who
were eligible for pfizer's booster now
in addition to those over 65 and people
with underlying medical conditions
at-risk workers are now included in that
as well to explain what this means dr
david agus joins us good morning dr
david so listen
what do you make of dr wilinski's
decision to recommend the pfizer booster
for front-line workers and those with
high exposure jobs to covet
nate this is the right decision for the
people of america is that people are
putting themselves at risk in their job
people who have significant exposure
need to be protected from the virus and
so she did the right thing it's in line
with what the fda had recommended so
it's certainly not radical but it makes
sense and i agree
all right so can you explain who
frontline workers are
frontline workers are people who in
their occupation or where they live are
exposed to the virus so that's
healthcare workers that's people working
nursing homes that's people who work in
homeless shelters or people who live in
helmless shelters it's probably college
students are in that environment and are
exposed or teachers who are exposed to
unvaccinated regularly in schools
how unusual david is it for the cdc
director to overrule the panel a lot of
chatter about that today
we are in unchartered territory it is
very unusual to overrule a panel but
it's also very unusual for the fda and
the cdc to recommend different things it
wasn't clear what would happen if they
both recommended different things would
the secretary of hhs have to intervene
we don't know so i'm glad that they're
aligned i'm glad they told the american
people that we are going to be
aggressive in terms of protection and
we're going to do the right thing even
though the data are not yet 100 complete
there is clear safety and it works to
lower the uh
a risk after exposed to the virus
a lot of jokes going around about people
saying you know i'm actually over 65.
you know it's one of those rare times
that people are exaggerating their age
up so how soon that people qualify for
the booster shot how soon can they
actually get it
well you can get it today and remember
it is people over 65 but it's anybody
with a medical condition that puts them
in higher risk and 60 percent of the us
population falls into that category so
this is a broad endorsement of boosters
for the vaccines to protect us from
coven 19.
now right now it's just for pfizer but
what happens if you've gotten the
moderna or you've gotten the j and j
shot do you think it's okay to mix the
shot to get the booster
it certainly is okay and that is a
discussion you should have with your
doctor if your doctor doesn't think it's
i think it's too risky to wait several
weeks to months to get those other
boosters get the pfizer booster probably
a little bit more side effect but
nothing dramatic and you will get that
protection we have to protect our
vulnerable and we may have to mix and
match to do that
all right dr agus always good to see you
thank you sir